hey I I just want to say that I cannot
believe that I walked into a koi pod I
mean seriously walk much
oh I should wear a snorkel to the next
business meeting that I go to Michael
you know when you think about it it's
not all your fault I mean who puts a
collie pond in a Lobby well you know
what you're right Phyllis but I've been
there before I've seen that pond this is
the thing I am a world-class [__]
please stop it now you're embarrassing
yourself it's okay we're having fun it's
actually not the first time I've been
embarrassed by a pond
well in high school the girls volleyball
team always used to throw me into the
frozen lake four years in a row
oh it was freezing no no no no oh
this is even worse couple weeks ago I
went to get a new cell phone and I
wanted one of those packages where you
have the five you know the friends
friends and family thing and the guy was
like who are your five friends and I'm
like uh I didn't even know I couldn't
even think oh my God it was so
embarrassing that was whoa
I don't even have Jan's cell phone
number and I hate her you won't give it
to me I was like oh well I guess I'm a
loser
too far God
thanks a lot man
thanks for the advice
you are absolutely right I need to go in
there and tell her that we can't be
together right
wow do it I'm in a very good place right
now thank you
okay
Jam
we need to talk
Jana's in a different place right now
a sign of maturity to give people Second
Chances
so I'm going to hear her out
proceed straight
well we're all for six
Last Chance is the Elmhurst Country Club
other side of the lake on the Southeast
side I don't get it I really don't get
it I thought this would work
do everything I had at that guy nothing
that's how it goes sometimes you know
you lose everything and everything falls
apart and eventually you die and no one
remembers you that is a very good point
make a right turn
wait wait wait wait wait no no no it
means Bear right
not there it said right it said take a
right no no no no no no look it means go
up to the right Bear right over the
bridge and hook up with 307. maybe it's
a shortcut Dwight it said go to the
right it can't mean that there's a link
it knows where it is going the machine
stop yelling at me
remain calm I have trained for this
okay
it's at the window here we go make a
U-turn if possible
[Music]
are you okay swim for it
I got you I got it
come on
come on come on
what is this
that is my Christmas card it's a picture
of you and me and your kids on a ski
trip having a blast skis and his
greetings no see
I know
we went on a ski trip right two years
ago with my kids and my ex-husband yes
but what you didn't realize at the time
was that I was with you in a sense I was
in your heart and next to your kids what
this is so weird hey dude just got back
from Jamaica
[Music]
yeah that sounds amazing but you know
what the lady Jan Levinson wanted to go
to Montego Bay
well I'm looking at a photo right now
and I'm telling you it could be in Maxim
oh
check this out
I am sending you
some email
you got it
no I
check it again hit refresh
yeah Mike
okay wait a second I sent it to you
at Packer Dunder mifflin.com
oh
I just got it from somebody else
wow this is hot damn
how do I get you out of this picture
who did this
it's obvious to me I'm not welcome here
but somebody better tell me who did this
or else I'm leaving well I don't think
Aaron seems to like you that's not true
I don't know her enough to make a
decision even what happened what
happened
Toby what did you do I think Toby's very
jealous of all the attention you've been
getting you know I would never ever do
anything like that but it does seem like
something you would do oh really turn it
on me well isn't that nice thank you
very much wait wait guys listen
Toy Story is all about toys that come to
life when people aren't looking
you don't think
it's not possible
that Woody did this to himself it is
Christmas no it really seems like
something Michael would do um
the fact that you would think that
points to the possibility that is
probably not me and that I have been
framed why would anyone frame me for
that okay I'm sorry why are we
discounting this whole Woody came to
life thing so quickly
oh
[Laughter]
surprise that was part of the party
pretty funny huh you think this is funny
I don't
but someday I think we will laugh about
this
when we tell our kids
[Music]
um everyone I'm sorry should I have your
attention please thank you
hi sorry I just have an announcement to
make
um
okay I have learned a lot about Indian
culture tonight
but I have learned even more
about love
and I know you're all thinking who is
this crazy Gringo and what is he talking
about well I'm not crazy
maybe I'm crazy in love
so without further ado
Carol
Carol stills
I would like you to do me the honor
of making me your husband
wow
Michael what are you saying
can we talk about this in private I
didn't hear you
can we talk about this in private
Kitty
Cake's really good oh I know I love when
they use buttercream frosting finish
your cake Helene I want you to enjoy
that
cake because I have something terrible I
need to tell you and I want you to enjoy
your cake
before I tell you this terrible terrible
thing
Helene I think you're a wonderful person
and I God I've enjoyed dating you and
being your boyfriend so much but I have
to consider Pam's feelings as a friend
and a co-worker I cannot in good
conscience continue to date you when I
know what this is doing to her Michael
it's okay no it's not I know that it
took me a little while to come around
and it's still a little weird to get
used to but
you obviously make my mom very happy
and that makes me happy
wow that just you've really grown
well oh thank you Pam and I hope you
were as gracious during
this next part
Helene once again you are a wonderful
person and you have lived a great life
and I envy it and I want it someday but
just in the future
you need somebody who understands your
references who is kafka-esque I've never
I don't know him
there's another woman
and her name is Italy and skydiving
and bungee jumping okay so and I want
kids
and you unfortunately have already
completed that part of your journey down
there Michael it's not my decision it's
mother nature and mother has very strict
rules about fruits
fertility
oh yeah I am I got it
I'm 58. what am I supposed to do now
well hobby stuff